I think the great political task is is
to refine and accelerate the evolution
of language this has always been
unconsciously sensed this is why writers
and poets are intuitively felt by power
groups to become to be somehow dangerous
in out of all proportion to their
numbers or the numbers of their
followers it's because they tampered
with the most sacred province of the
state which is the pool of linguistic
modalities that allow realities to be
concretize the place to hope for major
progress in the evolution of languages
in this domain of conveying our emotions
to each other if we could clean up that
signal a little we would all fall into
the dance and it would look a little
more like a dance rather than a
bargain-basement sale at Macy's which is
how it is how it comes off today if they
won't let us take drugs if they won't
let us copulate in the streets then let
us at least be allowed to speak richly
and clearly to each other this is the
most subversive activity
that we can undertake anyway because it
goes right to the heart of the issue the
issue being how shall reality be defined
how shall we define it and then how
shall we live in
[Music]
you